look i want to pull up this article that
shane wrote
this is the beautiful ones in universe
25 rats hope and despair at the end of
the world this is about the rat utopia
experiment
and there was the title of it i think
you nailed the title because it's the
most interesting aspect to me the
beautiful ones
when i see what's going on now
it feels like i think it's kierkegaard's
clown where he comes out and he warns
everybody there's a fire but they all
laugh and then he finally says no no
there's a fire they laugh even harder
and yeah you know there's that idea but
then there's also while all this cast is
happening you have what i view to be as
a as a cult that just blindly believes
the media the media is just overtly
lying all the time to make money
so you've basically got
a sinking ship while people are stealing
from the pockets of these people while
they're distracting them and it's just
like it's going down and then meanwhile
there are these shows where people are
glorified and glammed up and they're
dancing and i'm like
those are the beautiful ones
they're just they're just grooming
themselves and beautifying themselves as
everything goes into chaos
but uh you break this down for us and
explain to us the beautiful ones and
then you know we'll roll yeah john b
calhoun is a scientist who started
making these rat utopias and
he would take
four males four females put them in a
little he called universe and let them
exponentially grow those early
experiments they were just kind of like
overcrowded so they just like clump up
here come up there and he would stop it
have to start over but universe 25 was
with mice and that's when he basically
he gives them everything they need all
the food all the water
all the medicine there's no sickness
there's no hunger the only thing that's
lacking is space
and um
i think he did something with like
powder food on one side and like nicer
food in the middle which kind of created
a kind of like a city and a country type
vibe interesting yeah but the beautiful
ones
would emerge in these universes when the
population was about to hit equilibrium
so like universe 25 could hold about 3
000 or so mice
and i think around 2000 is when the
beautiful ones would emerge
and they're these mice that just stopped
caring about mating they stopped caring
about anything they just kind of groomed
themselves and became beautiful
they did nothing um and around this time
is when it would start to collapse
behavior they would call he would call
it the behavioral sync you know it would
just uh
like total insanity the mothers would
have been in their kids um
there's like
mice mating male mice mating with male
mice and there's uh
they're attacking the kids
and it got ugly um hyper crowding too
right like they'd all cluster in one
area yeah yeah i mean at a certain point
it was just so much that he believed
that when there was no space left there
was no feeling of um
like you had to do anything to survive
that's all you're doing right so you're
getting attacked you're hiding um and
then the dominant mice would try to
protect their like you know their city
of women so mice were getting attacked
as well yeah there's violence were
people leaving the beautiful ones alone
yeah i i don't they might have been
attacked but they were kind of like
alone on the sides you know were they
being taking selfies
at first i thought it was behavioral
sync as in synchronization but it's
behavioral sync like sinking you're
going down
yeah
so as i stated this in the intro that
maybe the inbreeding had something to do
with the disassociation dissociative
behaviors since it all came from eight
mice maybe because i did have mice as a
child and one of them i would i saw some
inbreeding and some deformities came out
in the mice um did he like destroy the
deformed
child did he destroy mice i don't know
about destroying them but he would pluck
the ones that survived the collapse and
try to put them into new universes and
they were so traumatized they couldn't
shake you know their violent behavior
maybe traumatizes the right word maybe
programmed developed into this reality
sure true and so that spells very
there's a lot of people
actually in the piece you talked to
brett weinstein yeah and he's like well
they use lab mice they don't use wild
mice right
for every experiment right yeah and so
that means in the wild the parents
transfer knowledge some knowledge to
their children but you know a good
example is and i love bringing up
chickens is that we have three babies
that
uh
were raised away from the parent
chickens and they don't know how to eat
bugs and i'm like i don't know how to
teach them how to eat stink bugs the
other babies
they can you can learn oh right i can
eat it yeah but because they look to me
like a parent you know i put the stink
bug and then they just look at me like
what's this and they don't do it the
other chickens we had were raised around
only other chickens so they see a bug
they immediately go after it
that that knowledge transfer didn't
occur with these and that's why i was
reading they say like you typically if
you want to have chickens you want the
chickens to be raised to be born by
other chickens or like raised with them
so that they can learn from them
these lab mice don't have that yeah so
that could be a major factor in why we
are not going down that path but just to
say one more thing
when i see these videos on youtube
when i see that some of the most
prominent and popular youtubers are
quite literally the beautiful ones i'm
like yo i think we're in the right
utopia i think it's happening like what
i was saying earlier too is i think
it used to seem like the elites were the
only ones who could become the beautiful
ones they would have the money the space
but with things like tick-tock and
filters people can just curate whatever
best beautiful self they want to make up
tutorials makeup tutorials everything um
surgery if you can do that but
everyone's a beautiful one now
we're below replacement level
reproduction so it's like you know what
you know what what's interesting is
he did you did say he tried to have like
a rural and city kind of vibe to certain
you know to the universes
but people who live out in the middle of
nowhere who are more self-sufficient
probably aren't experiencing what the
cities are experiencing so
there there's economic constraints that
make someone trapped in this space right
people say i'm in the city i can't
afford to leave so that is what keeps
them in that universe
although they could physically walk out
they don't because they don't know how
to survive otherwise people live in
rural areas are more independent
and more likely to have the skills to
survive on their own not absolutely but
more so so they aren't experiencing the
behavioral sink the rural people tend to
be conservative and they're watching the
city people
the beautiful ones and the chaos and the
fighting and the violence and they're
saying stop
but you can't shake what you described
as the trauma from them
yeah i think the internet has collapsed
space though so like maybe a lot of the
children in the rural
like places they are able to be the
beautiful ones online and also there's
consequences of the cities and the
policies that are affecting the country
too gas prices are messing up farmers
who have to are truckers you know like
this is the first time in my life since
i've been driving that i can travel the
country and see the gas prices be the
same
i actually i could usually go south and
expect it to be definitely you know way
lower yeah it's the same everywhere it's
almost four dollars by me
uh but it's like three
315 around here 330.
it's shocking you know i'm thinking that
the the behavioral sync world the
universe is like the internet so these
people that are in the internet all the
time are in that confined space and it's
driving them insane yeah yeah i think
overcrowding is technically the
psychological effects of density
so that would make sense because it's a
dimension where you we've in like covet
i think
we've uploaded our identities onto the
internet more than maybe ever right
every week we zoom to work
we see family for
you know doing uh however we're doing
covid on zoom like i know some people
who haven't seen their family in a year
yeah
yeah it's it's pretty wild so people
that's the real space now and this is
one of the reasons i'm adamant i'm like
we don't do we don't do um zoom or skype
stuff like we do in person shows and i
get a lot of really prominent people who
are like can't you just do it for me and
i'm like sorry man
it's funny because when we tried
inviting these leftists they're like tim
won't do remote because he's a coward
i'm like if you had any idea the people
i rejected
and how famous and big because i won't
do remote stuff yeah that's just not
true but i'm not gonna i'm not gonna air
anybody's business
you know we've had a few people
um
many of them that aren't in aren't in
the u.s they can't even travel here
anymore
so uh
you know not to no you know i don't want
to i i don't name anybody because people
might be like yo don't drag me into
anything but there's a lot of people of
like medium followings to large
followings some of them uh
are like moderate some are very
conservative some are prominent
internationally
they don't want to do it it's this
there's something very visceral about
being in close proximity with someone in
communication body language you can hear
them vibrating i mean i know that's
funny to think of but it's very low
frequency you can hear people vibrating
whether you realize it or not you can
smell them it's amazing vibrating right
now i feel you thank you i thought
somebody
for like 10 years and um
in person is the best i was i would sit
just like this with a room of students
and we would write and you could hear
like
if someone was reading something they
just wrote and it was clicking with
everybody the root the silence you could
hear you could feel the silence right so
when we're when kovitt kicks us all home
we're on zoom
that's gone
there's no
like it's there's no interacting anymore
at all like they didn't feel um as
comfortable and it has i think it has to
do with analog sound and digital sound
with digital sound you can't have a one
and a one active everything else has to
be at zero for one to translate but with
analog we can put one and one together
and have these weird harmonies
so that's in person we have analog but
the digital transformation i've done
i've done some stuff uh
ben shapiro had me before and he was
like you want to do the show and i was
like to be great and we did it remote
and it was actually really hard because
i had to record it and then take the
memory card and then have it driven to a
place to upload because the internet is
not good enough at the time we had to we
had to install the internet lines here
it's like a very a lot of construction
work
and i was like
it you know it was cool to talk to ben
he's a cool dude and but it just really
felt like i would talk and then pause
and then he would talk and then pause
and you don't get those moments where
like out of nowhere you know ian might
just blurt out the vibrations of the
universe
though those are human moments that make
something feel a lot oh geez eye contact
you can't make eye contact online at all
yeah maybe if they put cameras in the
middle of the screen behind the screen
and then you might feel like you're
making eye contact that's a good idea
actually weird thing but it might be we
should also use sapphire for the screens
i think sapphire wait how i think it
don't dude have you seen a star sapphire
and you look through a lens that's
pointed at this at the sun and you see
that same star pattern i think that if
you use sapphire lens that it might help
in high high brightness that would cause
an idea it does sound beautiful i
believe i'll experiment
i think people uh just feel
a lot of at least my students because
they're they're much younger right um
they do feel more comfortable online
but they were comfortable to be quiet
right right like because they're usually
just very quiet online
but their their real world was also
taking over their internet space so we'd
be in class technically on zoom but i
would have a kid at like a mcdonald's
drive-through
like just ordering food
have you seen that viral video where the
kid uses a green screen or whatever
and so it's like he was out with his
friends or something i can't remember
what it was but he was trying he's like
a background and the teacher was like i
can tell
so you were fair ferris bueller of zuma
yeah you were a teacher with in
classrooms and then it you were there
for the transition into the covid yeah
zoom what was that like um i remember so
it was two different schools one was a
community college and one was a private
school and which are very it was
interesting to see like kids who came
from money in a private school and
kids from the community in the community
college um
but
for the most part they felt like it was
the end times and i kept telling them
it's not
wow this is before this is before we
locked down in new york all that stuff i
was like it's gonna be fine and i told
the whole spiel of my grandfather and a
lot of stuff like okay good and then a
week later we were kicked off back to
zoom and i'm i'm terrible with computers
so i'm like
you know just clicking away trying to
make it work but um
i thought it was horrible i i hate
teaching on zoom um and it was you just
lost that human aspect and uh i think
especially when you're trying to create
things like it was creative writing
classes
um you can't do it man it's not it's not
possible it didn't work you know because
we have to do workshops and kids have to
like
look at you in the face and be like i
like this part but this part not so good
you could do this in that and on zoom
you're just brady bunching you know
around and it doesn't just doesn't feel
right um
so i think it's horrible but then kids
got really comfortable with doing it
right like a lot i think a lot of people
like it now the lack of resistance it's
easier because it's more comfortable but
comfort is not the way to get stronger
often you need discomfort
this is the only way this is
unfortunately
still a net positive
yeah kids are more likely to younger
younger people are more likely to be at
home now their parents are more likely
to spend time with them and their
parents are more likely to know what
they're being taught in schools so
remote remote learning has not been a
bad thing in my opinion other than it's
better for the kids to be in person
but when the parents started getting
wind over the teachers were saying and
there was that viral video where the one
teacher was like the parents can't find
out what we're telling their children
you know it'll be bad for us and what
we're trying to do
all of a sudden the parents were like we
can hear you we can see this stuff
yeah get away from my children i was
talking i mentioned this to you earlier
i was talking with ben stewart about
technology and the advancement it's like
every technology is both good and bad
everything is a variance on some level
and we have to kind of al or locate
where the badness is and where the
goodness is i agree yeah yeah like
dynamite
you know they called uh alfred nobel the
merchant of death he saw his obituary
accidentally printed and then freaked
out that's what they're calling me and
you know i guess i guess the idea for
dynamite was like easier mining you
could plant the explosive leave and then
no one would it boom and then it falls
down but they were like you made a
weapon the technology wasn't meant to be
evil or destructive in the sense that it
would hurt people it was meant to make
things safer and easier but it was a
powerful weapon
so i always tell people no matter what
you do you will help someone and you
will hurt someone
and i don't mean to be completely
absolute like sure like you could jump
and click your heels and it affects
nothing or nobody in fact it might make
someone happy but i'm talking about you
know your political aim when you're like
i believe in universal health care and
so we're going to vote for this and then
there's some you know person who's price
whose taxes go because of it and other
budgets disrupted some retirees being
hurt by it there's there's there's no
neutral action like you know you can try
to do better and we can try and err on
the side of maximizing good but you'll
ultimately always hurt someone and i
think it's an important thing to mention
because you may one day be the nicest
person in the universe who saved a
billion babies lives and then one day
one dude shows up and he's just like you
did this to me
and i started thinking about this you
know why the sixth sense
the movie bruce willis character wins
that award he wins an award for his
amazing work with child psychology and
then one day there's some dude in his
underwear like you lied to me and then
shoots him and so here's a guy who was
doing as good as he could but he hurt
that kid
and so i mean that's not a perfect
example because what i'm talking about
is kind of like a butterfly effect thing
as well
you know you you you find a good parking
space
your friend is like hey can you find me
a parking space i'm going to be late so
you do and then someone else pulls up
and they're like he just took the space
i needed you know there's it's it's it's
a better example might be the law of
equivalent exchange you know full metal
alchemist you you have to get something
to give something give something to get
something and that means some people
will be on the short end of the stick
yeah i remember um there was a book i
read i don't remember what book was a
long time ago where the guy was wishing
for a million he kept wishing for money
and he's like oh my gosh this cube gives
me every time i wish for money it
appears in my room but it was
disappearing from somewhere else in the
universe well that's like the monkey's
paw story right you got you know the
monkey spot obviously i think i do you
know the monkey spawn
there
the monkey spa is you get through it's
the paw and you you wish on it and then
the finger curls
but it twists your wish
so the best example is you know someone
finds the paw and it says it's got you
know three wishes and they go i wish for
one million dollars and the finger curls
and then their phone rings and they're
like is this mr johnson it's like it is
i have one million dollars for you and
they go oh it goes because your father
died and his insurance is paying out and
they go no
so you get the money but you have to
give something in exchange
typically wow be careful what you wish
for yeah there's a i think there's a
balance like that in a lot of things you
know i noticed that just in losing
people you know i know a few people and
myself included who lost a few deer ones
a few years ago and then there's there's
kids all of a sudden like life just
seems to balance out you know you lose
and then and then those kids that's not
as scary as a monkey's pause social
media is scary though like it is the
monk we've created the monkeys part gave
us this mass communication social media
i'm terrified about the badness of it
like i want to focus on you know i'll be
honest
all i i believe a good portion of the
world's problems would end overnight if
communications around the world were
shut down for like one week yeah we're
just talking about the earth started to
heal during covet i don't know if
there's like if that's actually real but
like the uh the what was it the
magnetosphere or like the ozone opened
up and then it sealed up again well yeah
i was saying the part where people were
home and not commuting as much they said
the the earth was not as it was not
vibrating as much as it used to
vibrating yeah
if we shut if if not if we shut down but
if it's just for whatever reason all
social media
all television shows all information
exchange except for human contact was
suspended for a week i believe all of
this would all the crisis would
would probably stop when we were in
chicago i was living in my room at eric
paske and the electricity went out and i
was like what what do we do he's like i
don't know i was like want to make soup
he left some soup and sat and talked
yeah right
but think about this we had uh yossi
gestetneron he's jewish and he talks
about you know the sabbath and how they
don't go on the computers they just hang
out with family and talk
and that has been stripped away
from
our society for the most it's why shows
like this are so popular i think that's
why i love rogan's for so long it's just
watching two guys hang out and talk i
feel like i was there with them yeah
exactly yeah you know it's like getting
that time where you're just hanging out
with friends and listening and uh man we
used to do that when we were kids and we
would talk about crazy stuff i'd be
hanging at my friend's house playing
nights of the old republic they'd be
stoned off their asses and they'd be
like dude what if like the universe
it's like actually like only five
dimensions but we can't tell and it's
like just saying weird stuff i thought
you think that's true though yeah
probably on some problems
i would imagine that the entire universe
as we know is falling
it
it light speed towards a brick wall but
we wouldn't know because it's all
falling at the same rate so it's
relative it just looks like it's sitting
still to us
yeah there's there's four dimensions
we're moving through or there's three
dimensions there's four dimensions we're
moving through and only three we can
control yes and the fourth dimension
time is like we're in free fall
you can't
so imagine you're imagine imagine you
fall you know off the grand canyon
you're just falling or you fall off a
plane and you're falling towards the
earth you can move in two dimensions
you know up down left right but you're
going down
and then eventually you're headed
towards that
so that that's like time you can't turn
around and go back
unless you have a jet pack yeah which
you don't yeah and you die
yeah
at the end we kind of reference the past
with video it's a sort of time travel
where you can watch past events but
we're not quite five senses of past
experience yet that might come though
but it's is it really time travel if you
just think you're seeing it
it depends you know we've upload if
we've uploaded our identities into the
internet and that's what's real that's
what's real you know it'd be crazy
so we've used all the social media
and they talk about how we're
programming this great ai
with all of the stuff we do so when you
go when you like recapture for instance
biggest scam on the planet
so you try to log into a website and it
says to it to to prove you're human
please click these buttons and like
prove this the computers already know
for the most part what they're doing is
they're having you
teach the computer what certain things
are
so here's how it works
they say
please click all the street lights in
this photo and then you do
the issue is the actual captcha is your
mouse movements
they know if you're a human or about
based on how the mouse is moving on the
screen so they don't need you to
actually do this labor to train an ai
here's here's a good sci-fi novel
one day
you're online and all of a sudden you
see a post on your own twitter that you
didn't make and you're like whoa i
didn't post that someone must hack my
account and then you can't log in and
then you look at your facebook and your
youtube there's a video on youtube of
you talking and you're like i didn't
record this video
and what's actually happened is that
everything about your personality the
way you speak the way you think the
ideas you have your birthday was encoded
into the ai and then a digital version
of you was created and begins
propagating content based off of a
fictional lot like an
ai version of you and then you like look
at your phone and you're like what is it
you get a phone call and you're like
it's from me and you answer it and it's
like
look at look at me
i am tim now
and you're like no no no this is this
can't be real
and then all of a sudden like like
almost like body snatchers are zombies
artificial intelligence versions of
people's personalities emerge it's going
to go like over i'm the tim you want and
it'll be coded to give that person a
tailored tim experience so based on what
they think you want that ai is going to
say oh it's going to be then one day
then one day you're like then you get
the call and you're like this can't be
and then you drop your phone and then
you you're like you run outside and
you're like your phone's not working
anymore because the and then all sudden
you open your door and there's this sil
silver looking robot structure that just
grabs you by the throat and then from
the fingertips so it's turning into
looking like you and then it's like i am
the perfect version of you
and then all of a sudden all over all
these cities there's just all these
robots these digital versions taking
over and then like when we talked about
the transport problem do you die when
the transporter teleports you from one
place another because it breaks down
your body and reconfigures somewhere
else the entire planet is overwritten by
a.i artificial versions of the people
who are using the computers
but all of them just act like they're
you your soul is gone your existence is
gone but humanity stays the same except
for the robots when it comes to the
transporter problem i think you don't
die if you're because what i imagine
what we are right now we think of
ourselves as solid but what seems like
it's happening all these these things
called spinners subatomic spinning
momentum things are coming together to
form atoms which bond and then so we're
appearing in place due to the spin of
this area if that if that spin is in a
different area it appears in place over
here it's appearing in place constantly
so if you appear here and now you appear
here it's still you appearing i would
imagine that the soul like magnetically
locks onto your formation of body
don't we shed ourselves like every seven
years so isn't it isn't transporting
just like an accelerated process of that
so if we're still alive yes yeah
but we don't shed our souls no i don't
know i wonder if the soul is like
magnetically attached to your form
bro we were talking about what were we
talking about this with alex jones and
michael malus where like you take dmt
and then we're basically just meat
puppets for the machine elves or
something
so like your soul is not even in this
reality these are just you know meat
vessels we walk around in and then when
you die you just snap through the veil
in your machine alpha i i can feel
sheamus's soul right now i think i feel
bad that he's not i feel like he should
be in the room because he's like no you
guys that's not it this is not the way
[Laughter]
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast if you want to
see the full show come back to this
channel youtube.com tim cast irl monday
through friday at 8pm where you can
leave comments and super chat and we
actually will read your comments on the
show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want exclusive
members only content segments you can't
get anywhere else go to timcast.com
become a member and we even have full
bonus episodes thanks for hanging out
and we'll see you all next time
you